well today is of course the 4th of July
so David America celebrates because they
booted we British out our monarchy out
our Mad King George dropped the ball
otherwise I would possibly be king peers
right now of the United States of
America so we don't obviously celebrate
it with quite such enthusiasm over this
side of the pond but amid the hot dogs
and fireworks even this day of patriotic
celebration and the states has become
divisive as a growing trend for black
Americans to celebrate Juneteenth as an
alternative to July 4th veteran
congresswoman Max Maxine Waters in 2021
claim a declaration of independence
wasn't for equality and it was only for
white men a comments were echoed by a
fellow Democrat Corey Bush who said
black people still aren't free so is
there something in all this should these
National institutions and occasions the
opportunities for reflection and apology
rather than celebration well joining me
now is best selling all through the war
on the western conservative coming to
Douglas Murray a country music legend
Lee Greenwood and my talk TV contributor
Paula Ron Adrian I talked to be a
presenter Richard ties all right well
Estella panel uh Douglas let me start
with you you read a great piece this
week for the telegraph about this weird
Trend I agree with you I think it's
weird where we've been compelled to just
apologize constantly for everything that
happened in the past
why are we doing this
that's right it's a very strange Act of
masochism really and an act of masochism
carried out by people who don't seem to
know anything I mean people talk about
the British Monarchy having to apologize
for slavery it was King George III who
signed the anti-slave reaction to law in
1807 Prince Albert gave one of the most
extraordinary anti-slavery addresses
when the British was still policing the
anti-slave trade on the high seas in
1840 to the anti-slavery league in
London all of this was addressed 200
years ago and today unfortunately
there's a kind of new type of malcontent
and usually also a huckster to boot who
just decides that the none of this
happened usually it's because they don't
know it happened and as a result they
look at our history and everything in
our country right up to just you know
innocent pastimes like cricket and they
decide to name everything as guilty and
you know you could do this to every one
and to everything but most civilizations
and cultures don't behave like this
because most of them aren't just
masochistic and so self-hating all right
Paula good evening your response to that
I actually agree with uh Douglas about
the fact that we don't know enough he's
absolutely right we don't know enough
and it's important that we do but part
of the knowledge is also understanding
the hurt and pain that were caused not
just about the good things it's not just
about the cherry picking and Wrongs are
not about being masochistic saying sorry
is not a bad thing saying sorry is
actually a very empowering thing to do
why does it matter that a bunch of
Royals now get forced into issuing
groveling apology who care how does it
change anything it doesn't do anything
in my estimation to impact on current
slavery where it exists around the world
it doesn't really make any difference to
institutional racism as we've seen in in
certain parts of society I don't know
what difference it makes it might make
people feel a bit better to see a royal
groveling but so what see I I don't
agree with you surprise surprise I do
think it makes a difference I do think
it makes a difference that people people
in power are heard to acknowledge pain
and hurt I do think it's important that
people in power have taken the time
whose pain and hurt are you talking
about it's not it's not people living
today these are going back hundreds of
years in some cases these crimes of
slavery and so on we all agree it was
outrageous it's been debated you know
really year after year after year we all
know this I don't think that people have
a lack of knowledge and I'm not quite
sure where the apology tour ends what's
the end game so the end game is about
the ability to understand the true
history not just the part of history
that we have been taught and that is the
difficulty so you're talking about who's
the apology for well the apology is for
me the apology is for those who have
suffered the apology is for those who
continue to struggle through colonialism
and free slavery and I do think that
it's important that royalty are coming
forward and saying we apologize for the
that's my question to you and you're not
answering it
if we all say if we all say sorry today
it was terrible which we all know yeah
can we then say right that's done we're
going to look forwards we're going to be
positive we're going to celebrate our
achievements learn from our failures and
we're done with apologizing and so how
are we going to learn from our failures
if we do not understand what we did
wrong you learn from your failures
because that's what we're doing at the
moment the sort of report you had from
man from your failures if you don't
report you did wrong if you refuse to
accept that you did because the the
Cricket Board the ECB they've just
produced a report they've reported some
of it was good some of it you can
criticize or question the point is we've
learned from that we're moving on we're
celebrating we're being positive
otherwise I'll tell you what it does it
depresses everybody it leads to it I
agree with that I think what it does
want to bring in Lee Greenman here who's
a big country star in America and he
wrote God Bless the USA one of the great
anthems celebrating the United States
it's July 4th obviously as I said at the
start here Lee we don't celebrate it
with quite such enthusiasm this side of
the pond we sort of take a view that Mad
King George dropped the ball a bit but
I'm happy for my American friends that
you have this day to celebrate you wrote
this great uh Anthem really for your
country
can we be proud of our country anymore
or is this kind of this desire to feel
this terrible regret about everything an
apology for everything does that Ma The
Pride how do you feel
well I'm going to go out in a limb here
and just say the people that I run with
and talk to and I believe me I tour
Across America all the time we do 140 50
days a year every dog house outhouse and
roundhouse and I talked to the American
public they listen to what I say listen
to what I sang I happen to be a country
music performer but I was born in
California spent 20 years in Nevada I
live in the south now and I wrote this
song because it was for Unity it's a
unity and for military sacrifice and
yeah America started as an interesting
Expedition and then an experiment and we
fought it out we fought each other in
the Civil War and said okay we're gonna
bury the hatchet here the trouble is as
we move forward a lot of people try to
change history I'm okay with history I'm
okay with apologizing for what happened
back then but I agree with you that was
back then let's move forward let's move
on past that and let's not change
history and try to change what happened
yeah I completely agree um Douglas the
problem is we've forgotten how to be
genuinely proud of our great countries
both our America and United Kingdom two
of the greatest countries in the world
it's almost like every day now somebody
somewhere normally on the left the woke
left is queuing up to find a reason to
hate the countries and their histories
well it's it's a kind of grievance
competition your guest earlier just
tried to engage in it I don't know what
hurts she believes she's had from
slavery all of this was addressed two
centuries ago everything has
consequences all history has
consequences and ramifications but you
know if we were to play this fairly we
would at least look at all of the
countries around the world that engaged
in the slave trade who are simply not
interested in any form of reparations
that the the Ottoman Empire all the Arab
countries who not just traded far more
slaves and across the Atlantic but
castrated all the men so that there
wouldn't be any more African slaves in
after them they worked with the bone I
see no interest across Africa in paying
reparations for selling their brother
and sister Africans into slavery or for
working them to the Bone to the present
day there is slavery across Africa today
in fact there are more slaves in the
world today than there were at the
height of the transatlantic slave trade
so some of us are simply a bit bored of
hearing people ripping at closed wounds
and then crying lying about their hurt
or their presumed hurt because everybody
could do this a million Europeans were
stolen by North Africans over the course
of Decades of the North African Barbary
pirate slave trade where would you end
if you did that the answer is you
couldn't end because nobody is alive who
has actually suffered the hurt and
nobody is alive who did the wrong and
I'd make one other point if I may it's
always the countries that people want to
come to who are put through this
struggle session Britain like America
and France are among are the most
desired destinations for migrants
worldwide and have been for centuries
why is that it's not because we're
racist it's because we're better it's
because we're good it's because when we
see racism we actually call it out and
recognize it as a sin try finding that
across Africa try finding that across
the middle east or in China nobody would
hear so what we have is a situation
where the more virtuous countries are
presented as the worst countries it's
sick and most of us are tired of it
thank you Douglas I am so sorry that
Douglas is bored by the pain that has
come that's not what he said through
slavery he didn't say he didn't say it
but what you're doing there but hang on
Paulie you're being very disingenuous
that's not what he's saying the viewers
aren't stupid they know they know
exactly what he said he's not saying
he's bored by the pain he's saying and I
think it's a perfectly valid point the
pain that people who are alive today are
claiming they're suffering so what
happened two or 300 years is not a real
pain they're not the ones who suffered
what was going on 200 years ago so in
terms of justice for all I mean I think
we'd all agree that well I'm not
suffering for when the Norman's invaded
this country I'm not suffering from what
my ancestors went through I noticed I've
not been allowed to respond all from the
Romans in other words where do you take
this I mean should I now be feeling okay
what the Romans did to this in terms of
slavery I can take it to 2015 when the
slave owners were common stated by the
government so I can take it to that what
is your personal thing and I can say to
you and I can say to you that I don't
think that apologizing is a bad thing I
think that apologizing for a wrong is a
good thing I think that the um Dutch
royal family have done a fantastic thing
in acknowledging I think all right what
has gone I honestly think it'll make no
difference at all